it's one of Rishi sunak's biggest
priorities
can he succeed where his predecessors
failed
can you stop small boats the thousands
willing to risk their lives to come to
the UK I am from Iran people like Nima
who crossed the channel three years ago
it was the first week we came to London
it is now training to be an NHS nurse I
need an asylum I am from Iran and I
could anasil I can't prove it with facts
and evidence
I couldn't go to embassador none of the
roots safe routes included me I had no
other options
to pacemakers risk my life come to this
country
but as thousands arrive in small boats
these are the latest this morning the
government's unveiling a bill that will
stop people who cross the channel from
claiming Asylum and ban them for life
from returning to the UK the
practicalities of making this bill work
are immense how is the government
planning to deport thousands of people
they want to scale up capacity in Rwanda
I understand discussions are also being
had with more third countries but few
think new legislation will be a quick
fix it will be fraught with legal and
logistical challenges the government
expects there to be legal tests but
hopes that the bill sends a message and
sets a dividing line with labor stopping
small boats is one of Rishi cnac's top
five priorities why is it not one of
kissed armors we've been really clear we
need strong action to prevent these
dangerous Boat Crossings they're putting
lives at risk we've got to work with
other countries to prevent these
dangerous Boat Crossings in the first
place and not just go for the headlines
that end up making things worse
and it's an issue that resonates a long
way from Westminster in in Stoke on
Trent one of the most lead voting places
in the country the local MP is out
speaking to constituents I understand
they do have to go somewhere but it
still seemed rather a lot in one area at
one time Jonathan gullis has been one of
the most vocal conservatives on the
subject of small boats I think that the
Home Secretary is replicated what is
being said in my own constituency and
those across the country which is when
we have 40 plus thousand people coming
here illegally is going to cause a major
concern for the safety for security of
our country but also undermine the very
principle of taking back control of our
laws and our borders
his is a view that chimes with other
Tories and one that's difficult for Nema
to hear I was in love with British
values when I was in Iran you know your
own values says respect other cultures
than you use this kind of vocabulary to
describe refugees who lost everything
you know nobody wants to be a refugee
but up and down the country in towns and
villages care about immigration
the Prime Minister knows that and knows
a political danger that will come if he
can't stop the boats Ali fulsku Sky News